Говорящий 0: Это подумать о том, что вообще такое, если тебя сегодня представляет будущее, период огромной декоративности, как выбрать образование, когда все меняется регулярно, и где найти опору,
Говорящий 0: и на что вообще мы с вами сегодня можем обраться, дорогие подростки, дорогие родители. Но для начала у меня вопрос к родителям. Итак, поднимите, пожалуйста, руку вверх, кто работает
Говорящий 0: по той специальности, которую выбрал в свои 17.
Говорящий 0: Пять счастливчиков. Поднимите, пожалуйста, руку те, кто менял свою профессиональную сферу хотя бы один раз за эту свою карьеру, за свою жизнь.
Говорящий 0: Я вижу уже гораздо больше рук. Дорогие подростки, а теперь вопрос к вам. Поднимите, пожалуйста, руку те, кто уже уверен и точно знает, кем он хотел бы работать.
Говорящий 0: Я вас поздравляю. Редкая одна рука в нашем зале, честно могу сказать. А, две, две. Это три. Три. Это очень хорошо. Но посмотрите, какой разрыв у нас между тем, кто выбрал свою специальность
Говорящий 0: 17 лет, и те, кто остался по ней работать. Сегодня мир меняется так сильно, что я хочу, чтобы вы вместе посмотрели на эти цифры. Итак, в среднем диплом и первая работа это 22 года.
Говорящий 0: Дальше. Сейчас финиш 70 лет, но по всем прогнозам мы с вами будем заканчивать работать 80. Что будет с нашими детьми, мне немножко страшно представить. Итак, сколько лет работаем? 48.
Говорящий 0: 48 делим на 7. Это 7 профессий за жизнь. Откуда я вру цифру 7? Сегодня прогноз Сферного и Динамического Форума говорит нам о том, что сегодня, в 2026 году, в среднем человек меняет
Говорящий 0: до 10 разных специальностей в сфере деятельности за жизнь. Если говорить о количестве лет, то, кстати, как вы думаете, люди, которые закончили в 2010 -2015 год, сколько в среднем профессий
Говорящий 0: они уже сменили? Какие есть идеи? Вижу еще варианты. Две. Ну, еще, еще. Вот хорошая цифра 10. Но мы останемся где -то между. Около шести специальностей ценили в среднем люди, которые
Говорящий 0: не так давно закончили вуз. Раньше, если мы посмотрим, то карьера заглядела так лень. Чаще всего, когда мы кроем алискость, мы предполагаем, что это ступенчатый шаг за шагом, когда
Говорящий 0: мы с вами растем, когда есть понимание того, как идет рост. И рост чаще всего вертикальный. Сегодня карьера выглядит как, знаете, я бы не плохо была с математикой, я не знаю, что это
Говорящий 0: за геометрическая фигура, и у меня надежда только на мой бизнес -партнера, а что это такое, я не знаю. Ну, в общем, на вот эту вот красивую штуку с точками. Вот сегодня она выглядит
Говорящий 0: скорее как схема, с которой мы с вами перемещаемся. И если говорить о карьере в принципе и о том,
Говорящий 0: как все это может выглядеть, то лестница уже не работает. И сегодня мы скорее ориентируемся на то, что готовить подростков и детей к лестнице – это одна из наших ключевых ошибок. А
Говорящий 0: вузы делают именно так. Следующее, что я хотела бы спросить. Пожалуйста, назовите профессии, которых не было, когда вы заканчивали школу. Ну, давайте через руки только.
Говорящий 0: HR -менеджер, фронт -инженер.
Говорящий 0: Коуч, IT -специалист, я слышу.
Говорящий 0: Давайте, может быть, мы что -то знаем про SEO, конечно. Может быть, мы что -то знаем про биоинженерию. Ну, давайте. SMM -менеджер, event -специалист,
Говорящий 0: HR -директор. Вот все эти профессии раньше не учили. И когда они есть сегодня, нельзя было получить образование по этой конкретной специальности. И как вы думаете, где люди выбирали
Говорящий 0: навыки?
Говорящий 0: На библиотеку. Непосредственно на рабочем месте. А если не получалось, куда они шли за этими навыками?
Говорящий 0: Да? Библиотеку. Библиотеку?
Говорящий 0: Блять, мне кажется, что не все уже знают, что такое библиотека. Но идея хорошая. На какие -то курсы, может быть, поучим, может быть, при фиат -правке, ну так далее. Интересно, что вы
Говорящий 0: называете специальности, которые, в принципе, предполагают достаточно долгое обучение. Но при этом люди всегда обучались на практике. Как вы думаете, что им позволяло это делать? Что
Говорящий 0: лежит в основе?
Говорящий 0: Опыт. Ну, у кого -то он есть, а у кого -то нет.
Говорящий 0: Интересы. Какое хорошее слово «интересы».
Говорящий 0: Адаптация тоже хорошее слово. Вот эти два слова надо сохранить до конца презентации и мы расскажем почему.
Говорящий 0: Вот сегодня, так сейчас вы услышали, дорогие подростки, те профессии, на которые невозможно было выучиться.
Говорящий 0: А теперь у меня вопрос к родителям. Вот исходя из того, что вы знаете, что на эти профессии нельзя было выучиться, какие советы по этой профессии вы могли бы дать из личного опыта?
Говорящий 0: Могли что -то рассказать своему ребенку, например, о том, как выкликнуть ДНСМ менеджера или там креатора?
Говорящий 0: Может быть, вы представляли себе, как работает промт -инженер, чем он занят? Как
Говорящий 0: будто бы, если я сейчас скажу, чем занят куклаутер или летчик, станет немножко полегче. Я уже вижу, как вы представляете, как рассказать. Вот сегодня мы часто находимся в такой ситуации,
Говорящий 0: что вы отличный проводник на территории, Но территория меняется так быстро, что успевать они просто не получаются. И работая много с семьями, много с подростками, с родителями, мы знаем,
Говорящий 0: что есть три ключевых страха, которые приходят к нам. Основной страх, он связан с тем, что ребенок потеряет 4 года и деньги на вуз, из которого он, например, уйдет. Или он выберет ту
Говорящий 0: профессию, в которой не сможет быть успешным, не сможет какогорлиться. Еще одна, ну, всегда лейтмотивом звучит история о том, что я давлю, или папа давит, или бабушка давит, но кто
Говорящий 0: -то из семьи обязательно высказывает свое мнение и теряет контакт. А если перестает это делать, то он ничего не делает. И есть такой страх, что он, ну, и продолжит ничего не делать.
Говорящий 0: А ключевая боль подростка и боль человека, который выбирает для себя профессию, звучит чаще всего так, что от меня требуют решения на всю жизнь, мне сегодня 16, а я еще не уверена,
Говорящий 0: что я буду делать в субботу. И любой ответ мой кого -то расстроит. И это, знаете, классические истории в совершенно разных семьях. И это нормально, если все врачи, и вдруг ваш ребенок
Говорящий 0: говорит, а я хочу быть и реавтором, и это воспринимается как какой -то миграинтный ужас. Или, например, у нас был очень интересный кейс, когда к нам пришел папа и сказал, что он должен
Говорящий 0: быть инженером. И я так чувствую, и я только в это верю, а мальчик хотел быть поваром. И вот в этой ситуации любое решение расстроит кого -то из семьи.
Говорящий 0: Итак, дорогие родители и дорогие подростки, еще по пару вопросов к вам. Родители, поднимите, пожалуйста, руку тех, кто уверен, что знает по -настоящему, что интересно вашим ребенку.
Говорящий 0: Это те же
Говорящий 0: люди, которые в 17 лет поступили и там продолжают работать? Или у нас сменились лидеры? Сменились лидеры. Спасибо большое. Дорогие подростки, поднимите, пожалуйста, руку тем, кто считает,
Говорящий 0: что родители это действительно знают.
Говорящий 0: Здорово, спасибо. Спасибо большое, ребят. У нас даже есть мэйдж один.
Говорящий 0: Когда и мама знает, и ребенок знает, что мама знает.
Говорящий 0: Могу сказать честно, что вот этот вот разрыв рук есть в каждом зале. И это не про то, что, знаете, мы в контакт, или нам, родителям, очень легко себя в чем -то обвинять. Ну, вообще
Говорящий 0: у нас сейчас есть тренд на то, чтобы рассказать, в чем мы были не до конца правы. А это, скорее, история про то, что в разговоре между ребенком и родителем очень часто нужен кто -то
Говорящий 0: третий. Это третий нейтральный, безоценочный, с инструментом и без собственного мнения о том, что важно и нужно вашему ребенку.
Говорящий 0: Ну, другие способы, помимо третьего, работают хуже. Ну, стандартный формат – это разговоры в семье. Почему это плохо работает? Потому что чаще всего родители не нейтралят. У нас у всех
Говорящий 0: с вами есть версия правильного ответа. И подросток ее чувствует. Поэтому разговоры о будущем –
Говорящий 0: платный тест в интернете или, например, в школе. 20 минут автоответ, который никто не раздирает – это история про то, что или прочитали и забыли, или неправильно трагтовали, или сейчас
Говорящий 0: легко воспользоваться ИИ и получить социально желаемый ответ.
Говорящий 0: Классическая история, когда мы говорим, вот ты хочешь быть программистом, ну говори с, вот у меня есть знакомый программист, или у нас дядя программист, или у нас дядя финансист, он
Говорящий 0: подскажет. Во -первых, это выборка из одного человека, а во -вторых, человек, он чаще всего рассказывает о том опыте, который был в прошлом. И сегодня он уже очень тяжело применим к
Говорящий 0: текущему времени. Репетиторы и курсы. Репетиторы и курсы, они отвечают на вопрос, как поступить, а не куда. И можно блестяще сдать игры, но совершенно не понимать, что ты за человек
Говорящий 0: и что тебя мотивирует. Пусть сам разберется, время есть. У нас есть такие действительно семьи, которые спокойно относятся. редкие семьи, очень редкие, которые спокойно относятся к тому,
Говорящий 0: что или там девочка, а чаще всего несколько, которые спокойно относятся к поступлению и говорят, что ну пусть будет время, она сама решит, посмотрит разное, но отложенный выбор, он
Говорящий 0: чаще всего на самом деле тяжело береносить ребенком, особенно в тот период, например, когда все пошли учиться, а он до сих пор выбирает. И коуч или наставник задорого, это в последнее
Говорящий 0: время такой, знаете, тренд, когда люди действительно считают, что есть коуч, он ребенок на доске. Но это всегда субъективное мнение одного эксперта, и часто оно не опирается ни на базу
Говорящий 0: профессии, ни на знания данных рынков, ни на то, что на самом деле сейчас происходит с профессиями. Ни один из этих способов неплохой. Они все имеют место быть. Просто ни один из них
Говорящий 0: не дает в реальных данных и не дает нам той оценки, на которую мы с вами можем сильно опереться. И вот выбор, который не бесценится, это на самом деле не профессию, а про знание себя.
Говорящий 0: И сейчас гораздо больше возможностей и гораздо больше преимуществ у того человека, который себя не плохо понимает.
Говорящий 0: Понимать себя в 16, 17, 15 лет очень сложно. Многие из нас из 50 понимают себя приемлемо. А для того, чтобы выбирать действительно, что тебе нравится,
Говорящий 0: тот выбор, который не обесценивается, это не профессия. Это про то, насколько ты понимаешь себя и насколько ты можешь решить, где себя применить. Любая профессия, мы только что с вами
Говорящий 0: мечтали, обесценивается 7 раз на жизнь. и обесценивается ровно одно. Знамя того, где ты можешь быть успешен, что тебе дается легче, взаимодействие ли с остальными. Вот знаете, даже
Говорящий 0: есть такая очень примитивная история по экстраверсию и интроверсию. Если я сейчас спрошу, многие из вас скажут, что они уверены, что они экстраверты или интроверты. Но самое интересное,
Говорящий 0: что в течение жизни мы все стремимся к интроверсии. И если у вашего ребенка, у вашего подростка Уже сейчас есть проложенность к интроверсии, то с возрастом она только подрастет. И выбор
Говорящий 0: любой экстраверной специальности, это на самом деле для него огромная не то чтобы сложность, но это история про то, что ему придется очень много ресурсов вкладывать в общение с другими.
Говорящий 0: Еще один момент относительно выбора специальностей, это то, что у нас у всех есть сильные стороны и слабые.
Говорящий 0: Есть вещи, с которыми мы рождаемся и на которые мы опираемся, а есть вещи, как динамические характеристики личности, которые меняются. Например, сам мы знаем, что примитивная история,
Говорящий 0: когда мы ребенка отвели в детский сад, он пошел выступать, и что -то пошло туда. Кто -то посмеялся, или стишок забыл, или еще что -то. И человек перестал выступать, но при этом у него
Говорящий 0: это дано ему нравится на сцене. Но просто сейчас ему это делать страшно. И вот у нас есть характеристики, которые мы можем увидеть, те латентные конструкты личности, которые будут меняться
Говорящий 0: в динамическом формате, либо будут знали. И, соответственно, если говорить про точное знание себя, то ни один тест интернета никогда не сможет вам ответить на точный вопрос. И работает
Говорящий 0: только комплексная механика. Комплексная механика — это батарея тестов, обязательно работа со специалистом, а лучше с консилиумом. И что мы сделали для того, чтобы помочь людям вообще
Говорящий 0: найти правильные выборы, и этот вопрос, куда идти, мы сделали проект, который посещен профориентации. Но это не про профориентацию, про тесты в интернете, это про глубинную диагностику
Говорящий 0: личности. В основе нашего проекта лежат батареи тестов, которая существует уже около 20 лет и изначально нашла свое применение в слабых структурах, а затем была адаптирована к подростков.
Говорящий 0: Это международные данные, когда профиль ребенка накладывается на ОНЭТ, это база Министерства труда США, которая содержит сейчас самое объемное знание о всех специальностях и тех технологиях,
Говорящий 0: которые есть. Это больше, по -моему, тысяч профессий через навыки, знания и условия труда. И, конечно же, это работа со специалистом. Плюс по горизонту в 1035 -го, потому что сегодня
Говорящий 0: Всероссийский экономический форум говорит нам о том, что 39 % навыков, которые открываются часто стареют, 92 миллиона специальностей перестанут существовать, Но именно смену придет
Говорящий 0: 117 миллионов новых специальностей. То есть если раньше, условно, в 90 -е было очень модно быть либо юристом, либо экономистом, и казалось, что вот прямо надо идти туда, и там всегда
Говорящий 0: будут деньги, то сегодня такие специальности, как просто экономист и юрист, но заменят искусственный интеллект. Но он не заменит нас, но он совершенно по -другому поменяет структуру
Говорящий 0: самой специальности в целом. И еще один важный момент, что остается в семье, это четко ребенка, разговор с холодом и язык, на котором дальше можно будет принять все дальше. Мы смотрим
Говорящий 0: не на сегодняшний режим, а на горизонт до 2035 года. И это как раз тот горизонт, который сегодня можно смотреть. Дальше сложно представить себе, что в принципе будет с высшим образованием,
Говорящий 0: как оно будет выглядеть, как будут меняться подходы и как будет выглядеть в список профессий.
Говорящий 0: Для того, чтобы встать подробнее, мы ждем вас на стриме, он у нас 126 -й с нами, со мной мои коллеги, это Марья, мы сможем вас проконцептировать. И Анна, Анна научный сотрудник центра
Говорящий 0: психометрики научной школы, высшей школы экономики. Это единственная на самом деле такая большая институция. В нашей стране, которая занимается психометрикой, занимается оценкой латентных
Говорящий 0: конструктов личности. Они расскажут вам подробно, что это такое, как это мэчится со специальностями. Мы готовы разобрать один вопрос про вашего ребенка. У нас есть специальная стоимость,
Говорящий 0: которая действует только в течение недели после выставки. И мы готовы рассказать про наши кейсы. Но перед тем, как закончить, я хотела бы задать вам еще два вопроса, с которыми вы будете
Говорящий 0: идти.
Говорящий 0: Вот сегодня на пути домой я бы очень подавала вас спросить вашего подростка, ни кем вы хотите быть и ни кем ты хочешь быть, а что у тебя получается легче и лучше, чем у других? Опора
Говорящий 0: на свои сильные стороны, она дает, чувствую, гораздо больше, чем знание того, какую генеральную профессию ты можешь себе признать.
Говорящий 0: Я готов ответить на все вопросы и приглашаю вас к нам на старт. Спасибо вам!